salut salut aujourd'hui on est au parc
de belleville et je suis pas tout seul
je suis avec julie avec julien on s'est
rencontrés dans des trains parce que je
fais des événementiels avec le spectacle
et c'est julie qui s'en occupe c'est un
train que vous connaissez mais j'ai pas
le droit de dire qu'elle transférait en
quatre lettres mais j'ai pas le droit de
le dire est ce que tu peux penser à un
sigle n'importe quelle cible dans le
monde ça peut être pour le coup ratp
non pas du tout ça peut être dur ça ça
peut être tu vois ce que je veux dire il
choisit quelque chose où ils mars même
une marque si tu me dis pas la cadence
ok donc une marque potentiellement je la
connais tu penses que je la connais où
tu es sûr que je la connais je pense que
tu la connais d'accord c'est genre aussi
connue qu'aux cas quoi parce que c'est
connu dans d'autres pays oui est ce que
tu vas me donner tous les indices quand
je te poserait des questions tu me les
pose rit je vais commencer par quoi je
vais commencer par peut-être chercher le
secteur dans lequel ils s'appliquent
d'accord donc je veux dire plein de
choses je veux affirmer des choses tu me
donnes pas d'un 10 me répond pas si
c'est juste ou faux une vie religieuse
je dis rien du tout juste passé
exactement ça peut être dans le secteur
de l'alimentaire sa peine dans le
secteur du quotidien pour tout le monde
ça peut être beaucoup plus
institutionnels ça peut être liés aux
services à petit à l'administration
peut-il aux transports j'essayais de
choper la première lettre tu penses à la
première lettre tu ne cherches pas mener
dès lundi ce ça peut être une consonne
une fois yaisien concerne c'est juste
oui d'accord ok tu penses à la consonne
ça peut être a b c d e f g h i j qu elle
mène au gie klm et nos pq est resté bws
y des accords j'ai deux endroits où ça
match
mais pour le coup je vais je vais écrire
le tout est décalé pour l'instant j'ai
le rlz on va passer sur le nombre de
lettres à chaque fois que je claque des
doigts tu appelles une lettre dans ta
tête
allez dans ma tête voilà par exemple de
cissé a baissé tu fais à tc etc
c'est parti
ces terres il là vous le voyez pas
j'allais mettre la gaufre aussi parce
que tu as l'élève qui font un peu du
mouvement en fait et donc du coup je
sais que ces êtres maintenant ok et ses
4 m j'y reviens toujours
bondues rien si tu veux je pense que je
les hais ce que tu peux leur dire à quel
marty penser à zara merci julie servir
oui oui 1 cuil
on se retrouve bientôt dans un train
dont deux qui rappelle non mais quand
quatre lettres fait ceci barça lui non
oui c'est parce que d'habitude fait là
que tu des gens mais là je vais pas dire
dans mon lit son numéro de téléphone 06
alors vous retrouverez les numéros de
téléphone dans le descriptif de la vidéo
si cette vidéo vous a plu si julie vous
a plu vous pouvez le faire savoir en
faisant ce 6 pouces en l'air vous pouvez
également commenter la vidéo je me ferai
un plaisir de lire et de répondre à vos
questions pensez à vous abonner à la
chaîne et rendez vous demain à 17 heures
pour le prochain mortal blog ciao